- So originally you were like
an athlete from Hong Kong?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- [Kelly] Like, fencing?
- Yeah, I was a fencer.
I was a fencer.
- Cool.
- That's cool.
- My parents, they were Olympians too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah,
my dad is a fencer and my mom's a gymnast.
- Wow, so I guess it
would've been a let down
if you didn't do something
in that category.
(all laughing)
- Yes, I mean,
I was prepping for
London Olympics back then
and then while prepping
I just told my parents,
"Hey, you know what,
I always had this dream about music.
Let me do my thing and-"
- How did that go over (laughs)?
- I mean, they want me of
course to go to the Olympics,
you know, do my thing.
And it took me seven
months to persuade them.
- Wow, but you were persistent.
That's a lot of months.
- Yeah, they were really against me.
And then they're like,
"You're outta your mind."
My principal told me that,
this is the worst,
worst decision you're gonna
ever make in your life.
- [Kelly] Have you sent him a letter?
- No, no, no.
- I think he knows by now he was wrong.
- [Kelly] Or like a signed headshot.
- Then after I debut as a singer
and I went back to have a
concert and I invited him.
And then he said, "Jackson,
we believed in you."
(all laughing)
Hey, we believed in you.
- This happens, it happens.
That happened to me.
I was like, "What?"
People were totally like,
"That's never gonna happen,
everybody has a dream."
And then they were like, "The whole time,"
you'd see them on news and they're like,
"We believed from the beginning."
And I'm like,
"You are a liar."
- We knew you were the one.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, wait, were your parents
worried about you guys
in the entertainment industry?
Were they worried?
- Yeah, at first I said,
"Hey, I passed this audition in Korea.
I'm going, I'm leaving."
And then they're like, "You know what..."
They told me about this, like,
"Entertainment, no
they're gonna kidnap you
and put you in a cave and-"
- (laughs) Wait.
- What?
- They're gonna do this,
yeah, like, parents.
- Yeah.
- And then they're like, "No,
you're not gonna do that.
We're not gonna see you again.
You're gonna be MIA."
And I'm like, "No, let me live my dream."
And, yeah, seven month of persuading them
and they're supportive.
- That's amazing.
- Do we have to sit this far?
(Natasha laughs)
- (indistinct) Sit here.
You're just so cool,
we're giving you room.
- We wanna adopt him.
(audience laughing)
- Come here, come here.
- [Kelly] We're giving you room.
- Nobody's gonna kidnap you, son.
- [Kelly] You are not-
- There's no caves for you.
- [Kelly] You are not going-
- You made it, kid.
- [Kelly] To a cave.